[Musique]
J'ai développé des ressources en
tant que géologue d'exploration pendant toute ma
carrière et
nous avons considéré la géothermie comme une
ressource unique où,
tant que le centre de la Terre est
chaud, nous avons une
alimentation électrique de base propre et inépuisable
[Musique]
[  Musique]
[Musique] la
géothermie utilise d'énormes volumes de fluides, de
sorte
que ce parc de stockage là-bas
quotidiennement,
nous allons remplir et injecter
vous savez environ un par heure de ces
parcs de stockage, donc c'est un énorme
processus de déplacement de l'eau
[  Musique]
[Musique]
nous avons cette situation unique où nous
pouvons tirer parti de toute l'
expertise de classe mondiale et de toute la
technologie de classe mondiale pour développer cette
ressource
si vous regardiez à travers le Canada, il n'y
aurait pas de meilleur emplacement qui est
déjà  pré-
configuré pour forer ces
puits vraiment incroyables, c'est parfait et nous pouvons
alors utiliser les travailleurs du champ pétrolier
et redéployer leurs compétences
pour la toute première fois sur un
projet d'énergie renouvelable
[Musique]
vous